la france rend hommage à la mémoire du
peintre balthus décédé ce dimanche à
l'âge de 92 ans il est l un des grands
artistes figuratifs du 20e siècle
un homme mystérieux qui aimait peindre
d'énigmatiques jeune fille un style
unique hors des modes olivier les nizza
nous retrace son parcours un chalet
perdu quelque part en suisse qui
ressemble à un château la dernière
demeure du comte balthazar klossowski de
rôle a dit balthus le maître des lieux
l'habitait en compagnie de sa seconde
épouse balthus rare et discret rares et
secret il est au milieu de la nature
lui qui aimait peindre un univers où
régnait la lenteur et la solitude dieu
fait la nature finit et a trouvé que
j'étais très bien alors si tu sais
qu'elle était vraiment bien
dieu a créé la nature balthus tente de
mettre du dans le quotidien la peinture
il la considère comme un chemin qui doit
l'amener à découvrir le mystère du monde
qui l'entourent
je travaille tout le temps avec mon
grand âge 21 ans vit toujours à contre
courant des modes fuyant le parisianisme
balthus s'installe l'âge de 45 ans dans
le château de châssis au coeur du morvan
où il réalise toute une série de
paysages non pas à l'intérieur du
paysage c'est pas comme un peintre
impressionniste qui se promène avec ses
pinceaux dans la campagne pas du tout il
se met au deuxième étage de son château
delà où il a installé son atelier et une
regarde le paysage de loin il y eut le
château de châssis il y eut la villa
médicis dont bell tu sues nommé
directeur de l'académie de france
autant dire ambassadeurs de l'art par
andré malraux en 1961 l'italie rome
venise et le tintoret admirateur des
grands peintres de la renaissance
valtus pense hiver le dessin domaine
dans lequel il excelle comme un art
majeur des paysages grandioses il en
viendra à des scènes plus intimistes et
les peintures de très jeunes filles qui
semblent s'exhiber innocemment seront un
de ses thèmes de prédilection
sans tapage mais par le jeu des
expositions de prestige balthus était
devenu le peintre vision le plus cher du
monde
rené char a écrit de lui son oeuvre et
verbe dans le trésor du silence